I just saw a picture of you in a bikini
in Jamaica your body is so beautiful you
are very kind no I really I was like you
are it was a thirst trap photo if I've
ever seen it I think it was beyond the
thirst trap it was it was I really think
inappropriate thoughts I but but I was
like well you know what if you looked
that good in a bikini yes you're like in
a full water setting angles and lighting
did you see the video of me trying to
make the video
there's a video of me trying to take
that picture because I usually do these
first dip videos where I like dive in
the pool and like I have the little
selfie camera set up and I'm like oh
this is me getting in the water for the
first time I got in the water in the
lagoon and I thought someone was gonna
eat me and I literally was like a horror
film yeah I thought this was gonna be
like the last video of the phone like
left on the side of the thing and like
I've been taken away by some sort of
Creature from the lagoon one minute it's
do it for the gram the next minute it
for Rana 3D exactly we still know what
happened to me because I'm filming it my
feeling is especially having turned 50
I'm like document it like let me see it
especially because a friend of mine said
to me your body now in 10 years you're
gonna wish you had and that's what
you're going to keep doing right I'm
gonna be I'm going to be 48 this year
Bravo I'm excited to get to any form of
Liberation as far as not overthinking
and worrying and I don't know I don't
know if I do that a lot well so do I but
I don't know if those things will ever
go away for me but my relationship to
them has changed that is perfect that's
enough because I I feel like my wiring
is my wiring is my wiring
um and some of it and that's okay but
now I have enough of a relationship with
myself to go oh you're doing it again
and then how do you comment in the
moment many many things I have lots of
tools a toolbox call the right people
therapy yep
um I you know they say your first
thought you can't help but your second
one you can
but I know to pause
um halt hungry and hungry angry lonely
tired my favorite because the big one
for me is just If I argue defend explain
Jade that's what starts to change at
this age chest Ife argue Defender
explain I get stuck in justifying
arguing defending and explaining myself
so much
okay that's the one I'm the most stuck
in yeah
this is this is like therapy I turn to
therapy a lot
um I also turned to my girlfriend's desk
I have a load of those is it true that
you have like an old-fashioned landline
or some fat line or some apparatus of
some sort that is like 24 7 on available
for girlfriends
um no but
um we have a text thread
that is called Keanu forever
for Keanu Reeves yeah okay how did that
start we're all in the same age range
and we grew up on Keanu I mean come on
it's Keanu so I was in the air in a
elevator with him and when he got on the
elevator I was like oh my God this is
I'm gonna I'm about to get married I was
like oh my God and I was like okay well
I could say hi or I could just wait for
him to say hello
and then I was going back and forth and
then the doors open and he walked out
I say hello wow
um I've Loved You Forever
um my name is Tracy I would like to have
babies with you I mean
my best friends and I's text chain is
named after no it happened after that
because I couldn't get in the car fast
enough because we had been sending memes
of him and then shortly thereafter it it
changed yeah okay I was lucky enough to
ride the Concord once me too and tell me
about your Concord experience because it
has the most wonderful story so for my
18th birthday I had on my walls all of
the supermodels plastered everywhere me
too I was obsessed with Linda Cindy
Naomi Christie just across the board and
my mom was asked by Terry mugler it was
91 to walk in his show The Butterfly
Show one of his most famous shows and
she said yes as long as my daughter can
go with me
so we my mom and I flew on the Concord
from New York to Paris we were on the
plane with Naomi Linda Cindy Christy all
on the plane so
um we flew on the Concorde I walked in
the Terry Miller fashion fashion show
and then
um I was shot by
um Brazilian Vogue and it's been
downhill since
my life has literally gone wow yeah I
want to ask actually like your mom do
people get emotional when they talk
about her because she was some do so she
is so meaningful yeah I mean she is I
like to say an international treasure
yeah she's a treasure and I think the
most magical thing about my mom is that
she's an incredible mom but from a
career standpoint she just broke so many
barriers and really set an example for
me as her child that anything is
possible if you do the work do you like
have the kind of relationship when
you're with her like do you like lie
down in her bed do you sit in like
pajamas and like eat breakfast is she
fabulous and like different like this
mom she makes breakfast in the morning
no my mom is such a mom
[Music]
foreign